yeah we more than likely should uh get
going
so i will start with this
lovely script that i have and
so here we go as chair of division two
of the house finance committee i find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor
as a result of the coven 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically this public meeting is
pertaining to the department of safety
please note that there is no fiscal
location for members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information
has been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should email lba underscore
fiscal at leg.state.nh.u
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their name
states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under
the right to know all so representative
lynn
if you would call the role i'd
appreciate it
yes uh thank you madam chair uh
representative bucco
uh yes i'm present i'm at home in conway
and there's no one else in the house
thank you uh representative danielson is
not present
representative heath mary heath here in
manchester new hampshire
at my home and i'm here all by myself
uh and i'm bob lynn and i'm president at
my home in windham
uh my wife is here in in the in the
other room but i'm here alone
and madam chair just to remind you i'm
going to have to leave at about 11
because i i'm going to uh gordon
mcdonald's swearing in up in concord
um no no problem whatsoever
thank you uh representative murray
kate murray is here in newcastle with my
dog and by now you can probably guess
where my husband is
thank you representative petrie
yeah thank you uh representative lynn uh
i'm joe petrie in farmington uh the wife
is
hanging around the halls again but the
dogs in detention had ate my trackball
okay thank you and representative umberg
yes i'm here at home in uh in
kearsarge new hampshire and my husband
is
someplace in the house so
right thank you okay uh
thank you all for uh being here today
and um i think we should
uh turn it over to uh
commissioner quinn and steve lavoy
out of safety and
we'll let you uh go ahead
well good morning um representative
umberger and uh
honor honored um members of the
legislature
i wanted to um thank you for the time
you gave us uh
last week i know there was some
follow-up questions and
some additional information that you
were looking for
from from safety um as we looked at
some of the gaps that we had and i know
uh that steve has been
you know diligently he started working
on it the minute the call ended so
i'm going to turn it over to steve and
let him
start and then we'll be open for uh any
questions
so good morning steve and i am alone in
my office in concord
and steve is alone on the first floor in
his office
well i'm sorry to hear that uh colonel
quinn um
that you're alone
uh thank you thank you commissioner um
good morning madam chair members of the
committee steve lavoy director of
administration
um so i thought that um you know think
it was nice meeting with you again i
thought as follow-up
um we would just go through some of the
materials that we provided the committee
um and i'll pull those up um if i can um
i'll share my screen and we can
go over each item um however briefly
answer any questions that you might have
there
um and then if there's time maybe we can
discuss um some of the items in house
bill 2
that impact safety because there were
some that came up
and we can obviously answer any
questions that that people have
at that time so i'm going to
start with um
so i'm going to start with the memo
which we have here
so there was a question about facilities
and we do have a mix of owned
rented and leased facilities that we
operate across the state
those are used by all of our divisions
the largest number of facilities are
operated by
state police and then also dmv dmv has
the largest
number a state police has the largest
number of owned facilities
and we provided a
the following documents showing the list
of those facilities
um
so uh steve r
are those facilities i know they're
owned by
uh safety are they also
funded all of the maintenance and so on
by
safety yes yes so um
can you see the listing now on the
screen yes
okay so the column here that says
department of safety
those are owned and maintained
exclusively by the department
so when we talk about our facility
maintenance budgets and reductions that
we have
they're impacting all these facilities
that includes the warehouse
and automotive garage in concord on
hazen drive
we have a dmv motorcycle rider training
warehouse
garage behind the dmv on hazen drive
there's the fire academy buildings down
on smokey bear
so there's an admin building the dorm
there's a fully functioning firehouse
and then also a storage facility
and then we also have the fire academy
north facilities so that's up in
bethlehem
there's a classroom and there's also a
storage building up there
i i did not include fire apparatus in
this list so there are burn buildings
that we use for training that's not
included here i
kind of treat those more as equipment um
but for our purposes of maintenance
for facilities they were excluded
intentionally
marine patrol headquarters in guilford
and marine patrol storage in belmont are
both
buildings we're responsible for and then
we get into the troop stations
so all the troop stations with the
exception of b
are owned and maintained exclusively by
the department of safety
troop b if you see is actually um it's a
joint agreement we have with the
department of transportation
and so we have an mou and there's
certain expenses that
they're responsible for in certain
expenses that we're responsible for
so we have we have um some funding
responsibility but it's not exclusive
um then we have the state police hangar
the gun range
um both state police facilities
and then the dmv in dover is the only
the dmv that
uh that operates exclusively for uh with
safety
the next column is administrative
services so dos headquarters 33 hazen
drive if you think of the department of
safety building on hazen
that's a das facility as is the dmv
uh headquarters on hazen drive so those
are both owned and operated by
by administrative services we pay rent
to them
and part of that rent includes
reimbursement for
maintenance that needs to happen on
those on those facilities
we'll work really closely with admin
services to um
to identify projects that need to be
completed um
and especially long-term projects so
like for example
there were um we need to replace all the
carpeting
over in the dmv facility in the last
biennium
and that was a long-term project we
worked with administrative services on
that they funded but we we helped to um
uh we helped to direct in some in some
regards
the ipoc um down in smokey bear that's
where
homeland security is the emergency
operations center
uh the fire marshal's office 911
state police the other people the other
tenants there are d.o.t
so that the traffic management center is
operated out of that facility
that's a das facility
the emergency communication services
garage in that area is a das facility
as is a laconia building up on the old
school
campus 911 operates out of that area
but it is technically a das a das
building although
in all these cases too um we do work
closely with
with the department of administrative
services and um
we've we've been known to help address
shortfalls they have in their budget
if there's an operational need that that
we have so
um it's a good it's a good collaboration
uh
the other das building is the milford
uh courthouse um so the the
the the courts um
[Music]
uh the dmv milford location operates out
of the new milford courthouse
and so that's another area that that we
don't have direct responsibility for
um and that's a rental the bottom uh
locations the dmv keen through the dmv
gorham
these are all leased spaces so we have
contracts with vendors
we lease the space to establish a new
space we typically
need some fit up costs it's about 150
maybe 200 000
depending on the location to to get it
into the working order for dmv purposes
but these are our leased facilities that
that we have agreements with moving
forward
so that's our that's our entire listing
the first column are really those that
draw
on the maintenance costs that we're
asking for in our budget
everything else to a lesser extent and
obviously with the least spaces there's
very little that we're responsible for
aside from computers and networking and
those types of things
um if there's no other questions on this
item i'll move on to the
position listing
i think we have a question steve
sorry i didn't see it uh representative
thank you madam chair um thank you for
your presentation
that um homeland security building is
incredible um i don't know if everybody
on our
committee has seen it or not but i had
the
the opportunity to actually work with
the national guard
and when we had a crisis in new
hampshire and i was just
amazed at the organization how often
does
that building get used to that extent
um is it just in emergencies or is are
there things going on all the time there
um there's things going on all the time
there so the the
911 psap the public safety answering
point
for uh concord that's one of our two
locations they're there 24 7.
so there that's that's where their
location all of the
homeland security staff that that
operate throughout the year regardless
of an emergency
that's where their business offices are
um the fire marshal's office
that's that's where his his offices are
located as well
um the it does get additional usage
significant additional usage when
there's an activation um and that's
where
the um the the the emergency operations
center section
which has separate um workstations for
each emergency service function
those become activated and we'll have
members from
from the administrative services
procurement team will have a desk
and the the the national guard might
have a desk
and state police might have a desk and
we bring in hhs
if it's public health all those
different components and representatives
from
all state agencies that have a response
response
response or a responsibility to respond
um and and yes it's extremely busy in
those cases when it's activated
but there isn't standard level of um
of operation that occurs because we do
have three of our bureaus
operate their all of their activities
out of that facility
you know you know representative heath
too i'll just add in not only with
colbit but
we've made such um significant
advancements with the technology with
being able to stream video whether it's
from
drones or our uh helicopter but
every event that we um managed over the
course of coburn whether it was protest
um
the issue with the beau power plant um
any any serious
incident we meet there at the situation
room and we're able to
to manage it from there and actually see
live video
and um you know and so so you know
unified command takes place here so more
and more it's going to be
getting used more and i credit rick
bailey the other assistant commissioner
with really
improving and steve's got some capital
project a capital project he'll be
discussing tomorrow to
to advance the technology there to
actually see
you know and allow the governor and
leadership to see what's going on in the
field
which um years ago we just didn't have
the uh the ability to do
so it's it's a critical piece of uh of
of government property
thank you for the question thank you i
think it's just phenomenal what you're
doing there
are there any are there any other
questions at this time
okay steve if you would go ahead
okay um so the next item
here is the uh position count
and did that's did the screen change did
you see you see the position count
listing yes oh i'm sorry representative
bucco had a question
no i'm not i'm chair um the question is
on this category that he's going into
now
oh okay do you want to ask that question
now or do you want to wait
uh well okay i'm looking at the 23
unfunded trooper positions and i'm
wondering if they have a dollar amount
for that for those 23 positions i i'm
assuming that that's a priority so
so um that's a that's a great question i
i don't have the figure
um off the top of my head that i could
provide that to you
those are just as a reminder those are
23 trooper positions that were unfunded
several biennium
ago so they were not funded in the
previous budget
we've been carrying these unfunded
positions for a very long time
and so at this point we're not
requesting
to have those funded because we have
other needs as well
but to show the uh to tie out the full
position count to what's in the budget
they're they're being presented here
thank you
uh would you still like to know the the
the amount of funding those
or um is that something that you that
you
would not need uh well sure i mean
if if you can provide it easy enough i
guess
okay um so that's the
so so the total authorized count is
exactly
that total authorized positions within
the 2223 budget
um as representative bucco mentioned the
next column
troopers previously unfunded those are
those are troopers from
previous biennium they were not funded
in 2021
um we have not had these resources for
um
for for several years and um we're not
requesting
to to um add these positions at this
time but they're there to show
they are authorized and they'll continue
to be authorized into the next biennium
and be available for funding if new
funding becomes available
the next column is newly unfunded
positions in 2223
so these are the positions that we spoke
about as our prioritized needs in our
presentation last week
and this lays them out into each
accounting unit
division and the accounting unit number
and name
to show you where the unfunded positions
are and that's the total of 50
in total 50 down here in total
these are the positions that we are
requesting to be funded if
if if there is additional funding that's
available and we have a separate
document
that prioritizes these as well as our
other needs
so then your total funded count is the
last column here
so there's your total funded positions
for the year so for example
if you look at the second line financial
management and planning bureau within
the division of administration
we have 20 authorized positions there's
three that are unfunded in this budget
so if if this budget moves forward as as
is there would be 17 um funded positions
in 2223
um and then we were asked to provide
what the funding sources were
um and that's what this is here it's a
it's a percent breakdown
general highway turnpike federal and
other
and so in some cases they're 100
funded by other funds for example the
first row here
petroleum pollution that area is funded
by environmental services
so that's work we do for the department
of environmental services so that's a
hundred percent other
but financial management and planning is
an area that is funded by the
many sources of revenue we have in the
department
or funding sources we have including
general funds highway funds
and also a mixture of other funds
the one thing i'd like to make sure that
everyone understands we see these
funding mixes and sometimes
[Music]
i i want to make sure that everyone
realizes regardless of
the availability of funds we do have
some ability
to accept for example accept general
funds
um and then fund a position that was
funded with other
positions here we would do that by
changing the mix in a different
accounting unit to free up funds in that
other area
so i i just don't i
just don't want the committee to think
that if there's something in highway
or turnpike well we know we have
we don't have additional revenues in
those areas but if there are additional
revenues in general funds
you'll see we don't have a lot of
hundred percent generally funded
uh activities um but that's okay so
there is an ability to fund
these other positions by allowing us to
reduce our draws on the highway fund
in different accounting units um and we
would be happy to make those adjustments
if additional funds are available
representative heath you have a question
yes thank you madam chair um could you
clarify
whether or not those newly funded
positions currently have anybody in them
um in this column the newly unfunded
yes yes there's there's nine positions
of the 50
that currently have um that are
currently filled
thank you and um madam chair if i may
one more question please
certainly um do you have a maintenance
of
effort for all the various funding
sources that you have to sustain
um can you define maintenance of effort
for me
i mean um because their federal dollars
often there's an amount of money that
this has to be from the general fund or
state funds
um to balance i understand so it's
millions of effort
yep so in some in some of the federal um
and some of the federal funding sources
that we have there is a
there is a it's it's a matching
requirement
um um not specifically in moe but it
there is a
there is a matching requirement in some
of the
federal um highway monies that we
receive um
through through nitsa and then also
through
um the mix-app grants that support
commercial uh motor vehicle enforcement
uh
and so those matching funds are built in
throughout our budget so that we're
we typically match those expenditures
with highway funds
and so that that does provide kind of a
a
um almost a sunk cost to us for those
highway funds to maintain the existing
federal fund
madam levels by one more quick question
just
certainly no problem thank you um
are are any of those funds at risk
because of the current proposed budget
no thank you
representative murray you have a
question yes thank you
since some of these positions come from
multiple they're funded by multiple
sources
can you just walk me through how you
determine
which what you're going to put where i
mean you have control more or less over
the highway fund
um but you know this one of financial
management some of it is general some of
it is highway some of it is
other how do you stretch that
out um with the monies that we give you
does that make sense i'm not sure i'm
asking it correctly
i think that maybe yeah i think i
understand the question um
how do we determine what percentages are
where we're charging
are appropriate in those different
funding sources
so that's really an area that for the
most part is
is um not exclusive to administration
but that's what we're looking at at the
top of the list
we we take information about the
services that
the financial management and planning
bureau provides to all the divisions
in the department and we develop a
weighted average
calculation looking at the number of
invoices we process
for state police for all those different
areas
we look at the the revenues that we
collect and book
the facility maintenances that we
perform all those different components
and develop a weighted average
and then utilize that to allocate our
funding
as justification to help support that
quick follow-up certainly thank you
do you change those weighted averages
based on say need of one particular
position over another position in order
to make sure you have money for that or
are your weighted averages really tied
to the usages of those
positions so um they're tied to
the activities not the position so it's
based on volume of work that's done
representative lynn you have a question
yes thank you it's really along the same
lines as the question that
representative
murray asked and i'm just sort of
wondering
um is it possible and if so
you know would it do you do this or
would it make sense to do this just
to since you have this ability to sort
of move
you know monies uh from one
from or positions from being funded a
certain percentage by one category of
funds or another
would it make sense to try to
re do a reallocation in a way that
um sort of prioritizes in other words
the
so that the the the positions or the
activity that you
regard as the most important and then in
a sort of declining
you know level of importance we're
funded
um by the most secure source of income
and then you know kind of reducing that
as the
as the level of of priority reduced
i'm not sure if that's very clear but
that's do you get sort of the idea that
i'm talking about
yeah very clear and um
and it's clear because that's that's
what we've done
so essentially that's the approach that
we took it was
not limited to positions
because we were looking at the budget as
a whole because there are operating
costs that drive those decisions also
you know we need positions the the best
example i can give you is
a trooper without a cruiser can't
perform trooper duties
so if i have a body and no car i might
as well not have the body
we um so when we looked at it
holistically we've made
several adjustments to our funding
sources
because of those issues because we had
weaknesses in general funds and highway
funds
and and it was a it was prioritizing
um those services those public safety
services
that we felt were the most important the
highest priority
and kind of working our way down from
there now
that that ability is the same ability
that we would use
in reverse if additional funding were
available to us
where then we would look to see can we
almost i don't want to say undo
but we would we would reassess where
those funds could be used
um appropriately to fund existing needs
including some of these vacancies
but that that that's something that we
did i mean as an example
um in administration we
when we conducted our our internal
allocation
or our indirect cost allocation to
develop these these
uh percentages we added um the criminal
records area to that allocation and we
we had never charged them for services
that we provided in the past
but that's a dedicated fund that's
healthy we know people are requesting
criminal records um the revenues are are
in a good spot
um they weren't paying their fair share
in previous budgets
we re-looked at that identified that and
now in this budget they are paying their
fair share
um so we made some adjustments like that
the other big adjustments uh had to do
with moving
entire divisions and or accounting units
from one source to another
so one had to do with the fire marshal's
office
fire safety and they were funded by
general funds
about 2.3 million in general funds in
because of the weaknesses in general
funds and because we needed to
make sure that the entire department was
funded
we moved the fire marshal back onto the
fire fund
100 funded where in the previous year it
was only about half
general half fire funds so
we made those adjustments um because of
the lack of funding in the traditional
sources
and while we would the the decision
making behind that was prioritizing
um certain public safety services
including law enforcement
um which which is a you know a key area
for us
you know judging that
those are great questions and like i
said i want to give steve won't take the
credit but
i mean this is a process to get to this
point he is thought outside the box and
you know
knowing there are challenges with the
highway fund cost of collection and the
general fund trying to find the most
stable fund is
is you know as representative omburger
probably she's been dealing with this
for years is
that's you know that's the question here
but you know we don't have these
conversations with division of emergency
services communications 9-1-1 because
their fund is
is more stable but you know what steve
and i have said
you know time and again is we just want
to ensure that the positions are funded
and um you know he does have the ability
to if you know we do can secure more
general funds to
you know to reappropriate it and blend
it in
to this you know this mix mixture to
keep the employee employed
so we do have some flexibility there but
it is a challenge and
and steve has done uh he's done a
magnificent job
getting it here but again we don't care
where the funding comes from
as long as um as we get it
sure no i i appreciate that and i and i
agree with you i mean it just it sounds
like this is really
a monumental task to to kind of do to do
that and i
i i i applaud you for for your efforts
in that regard
steve so thank you thank you and uh
commissioner quinn um
steve mentioned that you have uh
50 new unfunded positions
this time do you have a
priority list of those positions
or i know they're probably all priority
but uh
no no we do we uh we do mammoths
and i and i know steve can you know he's
prepared to share that
out of the 59er niner filled and
and how did we get to that list of
priority i mean
we didn't just do this in a vacuum i
mean we've been dealing with all seven
directors
you know understanding the needs but
what we've tried to do is look at it
from a department level in other words
we want to make sure when steve started
this
sharing some of these doit costs is we
didn't want to have one division
you know succeed and have six others you
know so we tried to look at
balancing the public you know the impact
on the entire department so
to answer your question yes we do we
have a list of priority needs
um uh the lab is right at the top and
steve can uh
he can speak to that in better detail
yeah i um we do and that's and that's a
document that um that we've shared with
you and we have that as the next
document if you'd like to go through
um i mean it's a large list and i don't
i i don't know
if if you want us to necessarily go
through each position
separately but at least we can maybe
i'll give you an overview of what it
looks like
and and you'll see what our priorities
are but i think
before i share that
i just want to reiterate what the
commissioner said
one all that hard work that we did
jocelyn c santiago she she runs our
financial management planning bureau
and she she's on the call i don't know
if i can see her or not but
um she's really um she's done a
tremendous job this is her first budget
she's learning the department of safety
she's relatively new with us
and this is the type of stuff that she's
been helping us with and helping us
figure out and she's done a
tremendous job so it's it's our team
here that that
makes this possible because it's it's
just so complex
but when we made these decisions and
looked at our funding priorities
it always came back to public safety
service delivery
and we didn't want to eliminate services
but we realized there would be impacts
and
where can we minimize that impact so
that maybe there's additional delays
but a service isn't cut and and um
that those were hard discussions and and
we really had to kind of dig deep to
find those
those pieces and that's where we came up
with these
these 50 positions the prioritized list
then took it that next step further
saying okay if we could fund some
which are the areas that are higher risk
higher priority for us
again to minimize the impact that
assuming we can't fund all of them
let's have the biggest impact that we
can with any that could be funded back
so all right uh representative heath you
have a
question yes ma'am tia thank you so for
the nine people who
will um lose their positions
will they have other positions or does
this mean that they're out of work
so we will explain yeah yeah so
that that's a good question i'll let
steve um
um take clean up on it but you know the
these are hard decisions to make and as
steve said
you know the the emotional um response
would have been to put those as the top
nine
but what's in the best interest of the
state and delivering this public safety
services so
we really looked at that and um and
placed those positions as needed not um
looking at you know individuals because
that's
that is what i think is our our
responsibility to the state
however there are our options and i know
that
it's our goal to to to find options
for these individuals and hopefully our
goal is you know at the end of this
process that um
you know that we'll secure the funding
we need for them so
yes we are looking at at more options
but
simply to put them one through nine
because they're funded
is not um that that would not accomplish
what were
you know our responsibility steve what
would you like to add to that please
um yeah i mean everything the
commissioner said is
is spot on um we we had discussions with
each individual
who was impacted um so that they know
what we know
and let them know that we can't
guarantee anything
but at this stage in the budget the
funding for the position
doesn't exist and um we're working with
everyone if there's alternatives
for them if there's vacancies we can
move them into you know that's an active
process that will happen
now through through the out the budget
process um
even but but again we hope that funding
will be found
at some point so that um it's really a
move point
thank you it sounds like
someone's phone is ringing
uh could we ask to please uh
go on mute i don't know who it was but
it doesn't matter thank you
go ahead speak so then the next uh
item to share is that list of priorities
um and so what you'll see here
is i'll probably make it a little bit
bigger so you can see it
that way whenever you and everyone else
gives me high strain okay
how's that a little bit better that's
better steve
all right great so like the commissioner
said like we just mentioned these are
really based on
um what the service delivery
demands are um for the state and public
safety in the state
um this list starts with all of our
50 positions um and then it includes
some other
priorities at the end you'll see the
first
six positions here have to do with the
lab
so these are criminalists um two
criminalists in
toxicology those are our highest
priority
uh requests we also have two
criminalists in our digital evidence
area uh and this is an area that's
really been a a focus
for the department uh and the lab
there's been an increased demand for
digital evidence processing everything
nowadays is on your computer on your
phone
um there's it's just part of much of the
case work that we do
so there's definitely a need for this
specialty in the lab
and so those are a close second behind
the toxicology positions
can i steve can i add to that just so on
those
that digital evidence just understand
this too
we're looking at um rolling out this
digital
evidence project to get cameras
body cameras cruiser cameras but we're
going to have to maintain
all department digital evidence think of
that
every photograph from a major crime case
every crash
pictures of evidence how is it taken in
the field in the cruiser
from the person and then transmitted
stored
and then uh you know ultimately whether
it's going to be uh
responsive to a 91a or get to a public
defender or to superior court or federal
court so
huge project which we have underway
yeah and before i go any further i
should probably just show you the
the sheet and what we have here so first
column is your
division impacted second column is the
priority
and we have the position name or the
priority name of a brief description of
what
the role is and why it's important and
then we have the total cost so this is
salaries and benefits
for 22 and 23 and then that's been split
up by funding source
um because i know that that's an area
that people were interested in
so general funds highway turnpike
federal and then
other um and then if the source of funds
for other if there is another we've
included that here
as well so that you have the full idea
of what the what the
resources are um but again like we said
before
um i i wouldn't i wouldn't focus too
heavily on those funding sources because
we do have some ability to address those
needs
regardless of funding so
fifth criminal evidence technician this
is really a critical role
in the lab if as far as logging and
tracking evidence that comes
in and then goes and then the results
that go back out
so this has to be done and if this isn't
done by
a criminal evidence technician it will
be done by a criminalist
and if it's done by a criminalist the
criminalist can't do actual
analysis work so um that's another uh
critical need in that area and then also
a
specialty and pattern evidence um so we
have two vacancies and pattern evidence
and this is one
that we would be requesting to fill to
meet demands for those services
uh the next section is the attorney for
in the hearings bureau um so that's
really the lead attorney for all the
adjudicative hearings
and they that's this is an area where
could the bureau survive without this
position um it could
but you're going to have decreases in um
and you're going to have increased case
loads you're going to have decrease in
the time
um and the amount of cases that can be
completed and challenges
scheduling things timely and there are
some things that have
um that have timing requirements uh but
um those we would we would prioritize
but there is always going to be that
increased risk that
we don't complete something within a
statutory deadline
if we don't have all of our positions
steve the other thing too with that it's
important
a lot of things have been put on delay
and sometimes the data you look at based
on covid whether it's
you know the drugs coming into the lab
but all of our inspections are auditing
on the uh mechanics and dealers you're
gonna see
all the things that are starting to come
from the courts once the courts the
license suspension the
the dwi trials the administrative
suspension so
we have to be prepared this position
always existed and the gentleman who was
the number two retired so
that's it's a critical position for
chris caskel with the bureau of hearings
um the next position is this is actually
a new
full-time position in the dmv it's a
program assistant to oversee the
ignition interlock program
um so that was done by a part-timer in
the past
it really requires full-time uh a
full-time
full-time hours to manage this position
and so working with director bilecki
even with vacancies that she has in
other areas this program is critical
and we need this position to make sure
that it's continuing
moving forward that position too
uh that manages the most at-risk drivers
we have those who have been convicted of
either aggravated
dwi or dwi second we've dealt with a lot
of fraud with the interlock
um so it's we're really moving in the
right direction but
but there's a lot of risk there and
we're trying to move that program in the
right direction for public safety
[Music]
the next is also a dmv oops dmv position
and that's a licensing examiner
these are the people who issue the road
tests to our uh to new drivers
and um again delays in service are a
result if we don't have people
able to conduct the um the the driving
exams
um as it is there's already delays as
we're working through
coveted backlogs because there were
there wasn't quite an opportunity to
have all those
um all those tests happening during
covid um
but regardless there's a general demand
for new licensing
and testing and um our our structure was
built for the
pre-code general demand and that
requires that we fill
fill these positions otherwise there
will be delays even after we get through
the backlog
the human resources technician in the
division of administration this is the
risk management position
so this is the position that processes
all of our fmla
requests workers compensation um
ada accommodation requests uh
it it they need to be the subject matter
expert
for all of these items and these impact
our employees these decisions that that
are being made
impact our employees on on in their jobs
and on what type of leave they might be
eligible for
it's very specific work that requires
someone who's familiar with these areas
and has a good understanding of the
ins and outs of the law and we're this
is a
vacancy right now so this job is being
done by thankfully we have
someone in our payroll department who
used to do this work
and so she's wearing two hats right now
um so obviously we're hurting in payroll
because we have to do these things and
again
deadlines and the such um the next
is i don't i don't think we need to go
through each one of these
okay uh we've got the information here
and um i can probably pretty much
guarantee
from the house side that
if we're able to get maybe one through
five that
you should be happy but uh we'll
we'll see what happens but i appreciate
the work that has gone into um
you know this priority list and uh
and what and and how you approached it
i think that that is uh is remarkable
and i know that obviously there were
very tough decisions that had to be made
and and i i really appreciate it so
if we could press on to the next area
very good thank you and and thank you
for the comments
um so then the last item that we have
is the list of the services currently
offered by the dmv
so there are online services that dmv
provides across the state anyone with
internet connection can schedule
their their appointments their driver
license exams
they can renew their driver license
they can apply for duplicates they can
pay their their tickets
so online ticket pay if it's a if it's a
plea by mail they can make those
payments they can issue non-guilty pleas
they can complete motorcycle rider
training applications
and then there's also a real id document
checker to make sure that all the
documents that are required
um that the individual has them and that
they're the they're the appropriate
documents
so those services can happen online um
but there's certain things that
that can't happen online and you need to
be in person
for um your eye exam which is required
to obtain your license
you need to take your your knowledge
test on site
um you need to be on site to take your
driving test
and so those are the services that are
that are offered um
across the list of locations here
we've got um the 14 locations
and what we've done director bilecki's
really
changed how the dmv functions because of
the pandemic
and um and it's really i think there's
some positive changes that have
have come of that and will likely stay
with us or may stay with us
even after we're back to a more normal
case so
the dmv has always had a call center
what really expanded the ability to take
calls and helps help employees by calls
at all locations
the dmv added a dropbox function to send
paperwork in
outside of each area so secure boxes
outside the location
so then the paperwork be completed and
maybe follow up with phone calls and
processed after the fact
instead of walk-in service which we had
concerns about social distancing
the dmv moved to an appointment-based
service and this is something that the
customers have really
had a positive reaction to so gone are
the days of
going to the dmv and hoping for the best
and standing in line
now you have an appointment and so now
at least you can plan your day around
that time you know whether this can make
be maintained
um throughout the normal course of
business as volume increases we'll have
to see
but it's been a very it's been very well
received by um by
the customers at the dmv and then we've
got our knowledge test
could you hang on just a second uh
representative murray has a question
not so much a question i need to move to
another room so i'm going to be off for
about three or four minutes as i grab my
laptop but we've got people coming in
it's going to be a zoo so i need to go
to a quiet room
i'll be right back okay no problem thank
you
go ahead steve and then you see the last
two columns show
the knowledge test appointments and the
road test appointments
uh and and the frequency of when they're
offered in our in our part-time
locations up in colebrook and gorham
so you can see the dmv really has a a
a good footprint across the state um
the intention is to be providing
convenient service
to uh to all the employees out of all
the divisions at all the departments and
in state government i can't think of
another one that has
that that really impacts this more
people than the dmv does because
anybody with a driver license anyone who
owns a vehicle
um they're having some interaction with
the dmv
so we're talking millions of people um
in the state
um but these are these were this was one
of the requests that came up what types
of services are available online what
types of services are offered
um in person and how can you obtain your
services
and so this chart kind of shows that for
you
yes representative umbrella i'll just
say that you know through covert when
covert we opened up the eoc
march 10th obviously you know commercial
truck drivers had to keep delivering ppe
we had to keep
we had to keep moving and i will say she
only closed for two days
48 hours to get things in place and
um i gotta tell you the the the money
that's been invested in the dmv
by the state has been has really served
the state well
if you look at that qmatic scheduling
system that's a game changer
you know we were dealing with thousands
of phone calls a call center that we're
trying to staff
now folks can just go online what is it
you're trying to do where do you want to
go
you know it's like booking a flight and
um you can cancel it
so it's like i said there are a few
services that you'll always have to do
in person
but she has checked the boxes off on all
these that steve spoke up
we've got three that are planned for the
for the future so
um i would say that when i said it
before
we're going to have one of the best
running department of motor vehicles in
the country and
i got a call yesterday from somebody out
of state that had to do service
with the dmv yesterday and said i am i
can't tell you
how impressed i am and how frustrated i
am with my own state
so again the technology is important
but the directors get some good people
there working at the counters and uh but
but the technology has been been vital
to
taking people off of phones and getting
them back and as judge lin will know
from his days in the supreme court with
j1
if you look at the advancement we've
made with the tickets and the not guilty
pleas and paying tickets and
everything tied back to that terrible
crash uh in randolph and
we're moving forward on the state to
state the automation of the exchange of
tickets
on the passenger side we have the cdl so
i am thank you for the support of the
dmv but it's
really going in the right direction
uh i have not heard any um
complaints about what's going on at the
dmv right now
and i know that over the course of
several years
you've really made tremendous
progress in servicing
the in servicing the people uh
and that uh and that i think is uh
is what safety is all about is
providing the services to uh to the
people
that that require them and that's
important
thank you great
um and so then the last piece
uh it's not really a separate attachment
we we talked about the forensic lab
positions that are um six of the nine
vacant positions are our top
priorities um on our list but we were
looking at the total number of full-time
positions that question came up last
time
so it's 44. um authorized full-time
positions
the nine that are unfunded there's two
in talks two digital evidence two
pattern evidence
two evidence control technicians there's
also an administrative supervisor
so our top six uh requests for funding
are the two toxicology the two digital
evidence
one of the pattern evidence and one of
the evidence control positions
and the others are on the list they're
just at a lower priority because again
the approach we took was
highest risk services ask for those to
be
refunded first but also acknowledging
there's still going to be a delay for
services
we want to minimize that wherever we can
and so that that really concludes the uh
the additional documents
from the follow-up questions that we had
um
from our first meeting and so be happy
is there any other questions that you
have
yeah this is um just a quick question
on i thought that several years ago
we had uh funded additional positions
in the uh in the lab because of
so we had gotten so far behind in
um in
drug stuff you know trying to
trying to figure that out so
is this kind of reverting back to where
we were
in the lab or is um
is this you know
something else well i think if we
if we don't fund these two toxicology
positions
you you could argue we're taking a step
back because we would we would start
having those same issues that we had
previously um there's still going to be
overtime money available
to help process things but we're limited
by the number of
hands and equipment that we have we need
you need someone to process them
so um again looking at our services
our initial positions being that that
were vacant we started with the vacant
positions
this is where they were and um said okay
based on the demand we're not shutting
down drug testing
but we have vacant positions we have to
meet these
targets that were provided there's only
so much money that's where the initial
decision came from
that's why they're the first priority
for us
coming back in because we always hoped
that there might be an opportunity to
fund
some of these as hopefully revenue
projections you typically get better as
we go through the process
your memory is correct too
representative berger and i think steve
those were seven ds
and at the time that we added positions
back in
we were dealing with back significant
backlogs on the drug
section side but with the law changes to
marijuana we're no longer doing analysis
on you know pipes and you know you know
you know pieces of joints and so we've
really focused on what are the issues
today but back to what steve said you
know the
the evidence the patent the the firearms
the ballistics the fingerprints so we're
looking at each section
where are the backlogs so they've
shifted you know it's different today in
in in will in this next budget you know
what is she dealing with and again it's
the fentanyl the methamphetamine but
equally important
the fingerprint section you know doing
you know
whether it's footprints or and obviously
the dna section so we look at
and as steve said digital evidence is
that's going to be
um something that we can't you know fall
behind it
representative bucco you have a question
yes i do thank you madam chair um uh
just
just so clarifying um
the top priorities was toxicology two
positions uh digital evidence two
positions
yes you can you could tell me if i'm
right or wrong
patent evidence was won and evidence
control was
won yes correct um
and i just have a question a related
question about the
unfunded administrative supervisor in
your notes it says that someone else
will have to do
his job if we don't have that position
is that
a priority too um
yeah so yes i know they're all prior i
know
um it is it's a matter of um at that
point we look at risk
and so you know the risk at
um performing the administrative
functions is lower than
the criminalists and the subject matter
experts and
worst case scenario a criminalist might
have to do some administrative work
but we can never have an administrator
doing criminalist work
and so that's why that's lower down in
the priorities thank you steve
uh representative lynn
yes thank you madam chair um as i said
before i'm i'm gonna need to uh
leave uh now but i want to thank the
commissioner and
and and director lavoy um for for your
presentation it's really been very very
informative and
and very helpful uh so thank you very
much and i apologize that i have to
leave
thank you go give our best to uh the new
chief justice
i will do that for sure thank you
okay um i think
that uh either anybody have
anybody have any other questions uh
mickey is there anything any questions
from people that are watching us
i see nothing but i think this would be
a good time to have uh
department of safety walk through their
house bill 2 sections there's not many
of them
and i think they can just uh go over
those real quick
i totally agree there there was enough
to make me nervous
in hb2 but uh yeah it's almost like the
bears for fish and game but
uh we'll we'll get to that another day
so okay if we could
um whomever wants to
start hb2
all right steve um mickey do you have
the
you have to share this
go ahead sorry did you have a summary
document of division two
uh i don't but i've got the bill i can
share my screen and uh
i've got them here so um
um because i thought there was something
that was posted on the division 2
website
yeah we put something out that was on
the draft document so
well i can i can talk and i can if you
want to start doing that i can start
talking a little bit about what's in
there
um you know for the most part
there there isn't anything that that
we're concerned about
necessarily there is one area that
there's a that that would require some
action
and so i'm going to start there and the
other areas we can talk about
you know our understanding of what those
are those new
uh requirements are but one area is the
um the establishment of a million dollar
fund excuse me just a second mary you
had a question
page numbers please uh oh
we're just looking at the document that
um
mickey put together for us
for our meeting on monday
if that's that's okay hopefully
everybody has that
in the mix of uh whatever else they have
on
their dining room table would it be
useful representative for me to share
the actual house bill to
introduce now that we have it because i
did that document prior to us getting
the actual bill
so if you've i do have it here
if you have the language there that
would be great
all right oops oh sorry hold on
i had
all right can you see which one are you
looking at now
that looks like it oh sorry hold on i've
got too many windows open bear with me
everybody i'm sorry
all right third time's a charm
all right
what do you okay you got it okay
okay so the first the first item which
is our our transfer authority
um this is something that's really
critical especially
it's been made even more critical
because of the additional
allocation that we've done in this
budget of
of transferring these costs in 27 and 64
um out into and property casualty
insurance also
out into um whichever dedicated funds
they belong to that could absorb those
costs
appropriately so this um this transfer
authority is is really critical for us
because those are typically accounts
that we cannot transfer funds
out of we cannot transfer appropriations
to or from
um and so having the ability to do that
in case there's a change in our
allocation
we we have estimates we're allocating
based on our best information but that
doesn't mean the dollars are going to
add up
exactly so we would we would this we've
had
this transfer authority for a number of
years so this would continue that
um one item for consideration
for this committee would be something
similar to this
transfer authority but language that
would allow us to
fund unfunded positions
if other positions become vacant
throughout the year
um and uh that that's something that i
could pull some language together but
what that would do is um let's assume
that all 50 positions go
unfunded in the next budget um there are
some of those that are critical like
we've identified
if if a vacancy occurs within that area
in a in a service area that we determine
is not as
critical instead of hiring for that
vacancy
we'd like to hire for the one that was
our priority
and so we would need someone's general
language to to uh give us authorization
to do so
otherwise we can't touch those unfunded
positions so
yeah mickey i this has to be
done by department
and transfer specifically no no
i'm talking about the unfunded positions
being able to
um fill them as you know as long as you
have money
um steve knows a little bit more about
the specifics of this than i do
i'm not i don't see anything in house
bill 2 related to that this time around
i don't know
i think there's just existing authority
for that for the agencies
well i thought i saw something in um
uh some of division one things but
i i have no problem uh
personally adding that uh to uh
hb2 so if and i don't think it's
anything new i think that's been
essentially boilerplate for budgets now
correct me if i'm wrong steve but this
is a kind of carryover authority from
year to year
yeah it's it is and um
and and the the position the ability to
hire positions though
is has has been specific to
certain agencies and so i know that um
health and human services has that
ability
they'll come to fiscal and they'll show
which positions are funded and unfunded
um we don't to my understand knowledge
we don't have that authority
um that's not a broad authority given to
all departments and so i i would request
if we're not going to be able to fund
our positions if we could get that
authority
okay uh steve maybe you can work with
mickey
on on whatever language we need for that
okay and represent murray you have a
question
thank you madam chair um i'm assuming if
it's in hb2 it would just be for this
biennium is this something that you
would want to consider for the long term
or
is this something that it's better to
consider it budget to budget
um we'd certainly
like a long term if we had that
authority long term that would be that
would benefit us
um whether or not it's uh that's
something that
could be done in time or in conjunction
with the budget bill would be would be
up for discussion but we would certainly
if this was formalized and
long-term authority we would certainly
be
welcome it yeah uh if i could i'm not
sure
that there is any department that has
long-term authority on this uh
representative murray
it's uh it's something that has
traditionally been entered into hb2
as uh for you know whatever happens to
be going on
uh financially but i don't think any of
us have
any problem of inserting that so
thank you thank you madam chair um
so the next section in hb2 is a new
section related to body worn cameras
and what this does you know in summary
well i'm not going to read the whole
thing but essentially this establishes a
fund
in the department of safety to provide
grants
to local police departments to help
encourage them to implement
body cameras and so um
it's a million dollars that's
appropriated to start off
and it's a non-lapsing i believe it's a
non-lapsing um
fund that's established and um this is
certainly something that that that we
um that we support in in concept this is
a lee act recommendation
um that that body cameras be in use
in law enforcement across the state this
would not directly
provide any support for state police so
this is not state police state police
body cameras are within our existing
operating budget
this is additional grant funding to for
locals kind of as
a matching component this language
requires the commissioner of safety to
work with the
attorney general and establish the the
administrative rules surrounding
what needs to be submitted and who can
obtain these funds
and so that would that would be
established what this does not
include currently is any support to
administer the program
and so that's the piece that um we would
request of the committee
we spoke with our grants management area
that that falls under
my division under division of
administration and um
i can tell you that we're stretched as
thin as possible in that
area we have people working on multiple
grants and they really
there's no resources to move to help get
this thing
going to where it needs to be so we
would likely
to make this happen we would need a a
program specialist 2 position
it's
i was looking at the i was looking at
the amounts but it's about eighty
thousand dollars
a year salary and benefits um
for that role um and that's
we think that that position embedded
within our grants management unit
um we could utilize the um the the
the processes that we have for our
existing grant uh distributions
but we'd have that person who'd be
responsible for this because this is
going to get complicated fast
now we i don't expect all
all 200 towns and municipalities with
police forces to participate
some may say we don't want to
participate but i think there will be a
large
response to this and so for those of you
familiar with the compliance of grants
and and the application process there's
a lot of administrative work
and we think that um the best practice
is always if there's a new program you
put someone in charge of it
this person would be in charge of it so
that would be something that's not
funded or brought up here that we would
also request
one of the one of the areas that
is sorry representative i'll let you go
first
thank you madam chair um my question is
a quick one um have you maxed out all
your federal funds
that might be used for this and or if we
get
new funds related to that could be used
in this area would this that be a
possibility for you
so we have uh maxed out our
administrative
uh draws for federal funding um so that
was the first place we looked
um and then um as far as the coveted
piece that's a great question
um i i don't know what the what the
restrictions
would be if there's um if there is
money to states that that comes forward
and whether this would qualify so
we would have to look at the eligibility
um for that
so representative umberger just to share
with you
the one thing that i'm really uh
focused on and um there's a lot of
i would say nervousness is our own
camera project
and as you know steve knows we've got
money in our own budget
we just extended the rfp out because
we're looking at
other options for downloading because
we've got troopers
you know in all corners of the state
some with connectivity some without so
we've got our we've got our uh
we're gonna try and focus on our own
project so this is completely separate
and i
am getting a lot of phone calls from
folks saying you know
you know how would i get money can we
just share some of your technology well
we haven't even got our own you know up
and running yet so
we're going to have a lot of work over
the next biennium but thankfully you
know
rick bailey and steve and the team you
know but
i i've got to focus on department of
safety and and
the liax you know we we're mandated we
are going to
have body cameras and in cruiser cameras
on uniform troopers
this is completely separate leak
recommended
local law enforcement you know you know
utilize body cameras but again there was
no funding so this
is an opportunity and again it's you
know this is in the
just in the infancy stages but to
steve's point i agree with him if this
is going to be successful
he's got to have somebody to run the
program or at least assist the grants
management team
um our
one of the things that as i talked to
some of the
local folks about body cameras and
dash cams the
the digital keeping of all these records
is going to be phenomenal
and i'm not sure that we have
any rules or laws or whatever you want
in place
to try to handle how long do we have to
keep these things
um you know because it it's going to be
a dis
well i shouldn't say that it's going to
be very difficult
for uh local police to uh
to manage this not only you know
financially
but in uh in a in trying to
manage the the actual digitizing
of all of this stuff so i have some i
have some good news for your
representative
so steve will share the statue there is
a statute in place
for body cameras which lays out you know
defines you know retention you know
whether it's an office involved shooting
or
so that is like that isn't statute as of
now
and again you know whatever company that
whether it's a small
department um the departments where all
the police officers
come and go and share cars that their
their storage solution can be somewhat
different because they've got like a hot
swap and it can be done there
um but you're correct it's the it's the
storage and that's what rick bailey has
been
uh why our rfp would put so much work
into it
and thankfully you know dennis coulee
and rick and
and a team we want to make sure we get
it right because if you're a trooper
and you're in colombia and you've just
been on patrol for eight hours and
you've got
maybe you've stopped several cars made
an arrest so how much
how much data is on your uh cruiser
camera
and in your body camera and how do we
get it to that secure location
and then from there once it's there if
you made a dwi arrest
how does it go to the bureau of hearings
how does it go to the courts
if you've got a 91a so it's it's the
storage
and the management of this information
because as you know everybody's going to
you know want to get access and we have
to make sure that so
um and again we have the right people in
place
i i believe we'll get there but i just
want to make sure that
everybody understands this is a very
very very big project
that we have underway
i don't mickey could you move the
uh the body camera thing up a little bit
okay it says that you have to
within 180 days
jointly establish a process for
application
and um
what what you're telling me if i
understood correctly
is that that is probably
a little bit too soon from your
perspective
no i don't think um this is just
i i think that's establishing the
process for application
so i think that's doable and then from
there
once they have the funds it would be
incumbent on the police department
you know let's say part of the
application is you've got to ensure that
look at you've got a proposal you've got
a defined number of police officers
and you can you know with let's say you
applied for
you know a hundred thousand dollars
we've got x amount of police officers
we've got a vendor we can do it
um so i think and again i don't want to
overstate it but i think that is
that is uh i think that's doable
so i think i think the 180 days is
probably
um
um it's probably it's probably fine to
develop the process
i think that we could develop the
process in the in that six months that's
six months right 180 days six months
um um i think in months the days always
throw me off
um the the the the concern i have is
that um
everything needs to be adopted by rule
in rulemaking
and so that's where i think the delay
might come in
and so it might make more sense to have
this
to have this um extended out for
for a full for a year
or maybe at least nine months to allow
for the rulemaking process
because i'm assuming we wouldn't want to
go through emergency rulemaking
for something like this but again that
would be the legislature could always
decide that no that's that's fine that's
appropriate
we want to we want to go that route but
that's what my concern would be is the
rule making piece
maybe holding it up but i think the
commissioner and the attorney general
could come up with the process within
180 days without without an issue
the statue to representatives 105
dash d colon 2 use of body one cameras
thank you um are you
are you foreseeing the same vendor
that you would you would tell the uh
the police departments
that they all should use
this vendor so that the um
the information is seamless
from the local level all the way through
so so you know i'm gonna i'm gonna step
out on a on a limb here and i think that
um i i i don't think that that
is what we would be doing because like i
said you know that you know the
the rules with proposals and and and
the requirements of confidentiality but
we're we have no idea right now what's
going to be the best
um the best vendor for our needs
so every department i think will have
some unique needs
and i think that you know they will you
know they will
have the ability and flexibility to seek
the best vendor for themselves
maybe it's one that you know they know
but i don't think we
i think we are just going to provide the
resources but to ensure that
you know i think what's important is if
we're going to fund it we kind of have a
baseline on
what the costs are understanding what
you know kind of some costs are
and making sure that um they buy the
equipment that
that we need now like we're gonna have
we're looking at body cameras and in
cruiser cameras
front and rear so that be actually three
so a department may just want body
cameras but i think this
grant here is for would be for body
cameras
and again it's it's not mandatory um so
i think you'll see a lot of interest in
it though quite honestly i think a lot
of department's going to look to
us for funding and i don't know how far
the
money will go but you know i think to
steve's point i think we can get
i think i will work closely with the um
the next attorney general
to get the process in place and i think
i think we can do it though
we'll get it done representative bucco
you have a question
thank you madam chair i'm just curious
with all this data
uh are we going to be starting do we
need our own servers or how are we going
to be storing all this material
so we the state will be worrying about
the 270 some odd you know state police
troopers that's what our we will be
doing with our project that we're going
to have to fund separately
the local departments will have to do
their own i've talked to
many local chiefs that have them now and
there's no issues
they've got their own storage maybe some
of the clouds some have servers but
um so they'll you know i think they'll
manage it on their own you know
manchester's you know
gone in their own direction i know um
and some have had them for several years
we're
actually behind you know many of the
departments
thank you yes sir
okay mickey i think we've had enough fun
body cameras let's go to
radio infrastructure this is really
so i also just want to make you aware
the way that the bill was drafted
section 145 lumps in
the body camera fund as well as the
commission established to uh
receive the complaints alleging
misconduct um
there's no real tie to the department of
safety with that or the appropriation
i feel like this was a drafting
oversight it probably should have been
separate sections so we may have to
coordinate a little bit with division
one
as far as what to do um with this one
section there is an appropriation that
is included actually in the department
of administrative services budget
because it's an independent commission
but just that's why you see
that section kind of lumped in between
some of these safety related sections
just wanted to point that out
i don't know if you want to talk to the
department about that or just move on to
the
the radio uh section down here on
section
148 or excuse me 149.
uh i think you're muted representative
thanks
does the uh safety have any input that
they
like to make on that no i understand it
and i you know i haven't been involved
with lee act i know what the vision was
so
i think mickey explains just well and
i'm sure he'll he'll get it cleaned up
okay thank you so the next section would
be 149 related to the radio
infrastructure equipment
purchase
yeah so this so this is an area that um
we had a lot of discussion with
and this has been an ongoing um kind of
question
across the state for for years now uh
our division of emergency services and
communications
uh operates the state police radio
network
and that network is actually utilized by
um
other departments as well and so we've
been providing services
um maintenance of equipment um
and uh to to divisions across the state
um free of charge for a very long time
we haven't had agreements to charge back
to different funds
you know we're we've always kind of
struggled with this is that what's the
right model for this should we have a
separate system
that everyone runs their own radio
should we have a state centralized
system
and um the reality is is that
there's a lot of potential for us to to
gain efficiencies
if we if we work together to kind of
have some sort of governance over the
state systems
interoperability's really driven this
because that's
that that's been the challenge if you
run separate systems your equipment
can't communicate with others
and the more and more we're being asked
to
operate with a full statewide response
not just a department of safety response
and so what this language does is um it
starts to build that
structure around our radio
infrastructure and looking at it
holistically
and acknowledging that it's a statewide
system with a statewide response
with different needs at the department
levels but
we should probably look at the system
infrastructure itself
as a whole and and this would create um
would would create an opportunity for
911 the division of emergency services
and communications
to work with these other divisions and
other departments across the state
um to to identify ways that we can
collaborate
and um and and be smart about
the investments we make within our radio
infrastructure
to have the biggest and broadest impact
possible
and not build a small network um to
service one department
um which inadvertently walled off of
benefits that could be achieved from
others
and i probably i turned over to the
commissioner to add add any other
information
that he wants to share about the
importance of this because it's
something that we've been talking about
for a while
um and it's certainly it's it's
certainly uh um
in my opinion the right way to go so so
i'll just add in
in two minutes um in
2014 i was the colonel and i was
involved with a performance audit
of uh state department safety statewide
radio interoperability i have the lba
report
here now and having gone through each
one of those
um long short um there was
some great recommendations here on you
know what's the long-term planning
what's the consolidation i think there
was a belief that department of safety
at the time
managed this you know super you know
system
of radio interoperability but as the
audit points out there are so many
separate and unique systems and so the
recommendations
i'll just read one line the state did
not have a viable integrated strategic
radio
interoperability plan to provide clear
goals and objectives
defining the desired end state for
interoperability
since 2014 over the last you know uh
six six plus years we've made some
significant advancements
at uh desc and um this piece here
essentially ensures that similar to like
i.t
oversight and governance making sure
that you know
agencies when we're making these
purchases large purchases
there's a process so that they are
interoperability there's not a redundant
purchase and i know that
director doyle mark doyle and his team
have been dealing with other
leaders in state government looking at
some um whether it's capital projects
and do we really need this
are there areas where we can combine
consolidate
and um so we have continued to look at
this performance audit the
recommendations
and i think we've made some advancements
and this this is a piece here that will
ensure that
you know uh in short where the purchases
are
are are needed and necessary for
interoperability and there's no
redundant
you know uh system or equipment in place
now so but yeah so yeah there's
there is i have i do have this question
it says
um the department
shall annually review and set dollar
or other limit limits for purchases and
contracts
and that the director of the division
emergency
management before
so this
this now requires you
to review all of the um
[Music]
the contracts
and um i you know what one could
interpret this to say
since you're setting the dollar limits
then you are fun
i mean i'm i'm just a little concerned
about
that section three
yeah and i think i think
go ahead mary
madame jimmy oh um
again i'm gonna ask my same question it
would seem like
this um system
um would fall into maybe something that
federal funds
could be utilized for certainly um when
we had
911 and and then we have emergencies
across the state
or nationally this would seem to be
something that would be an asset to that
because it would upgrade the system and
just have people talking to
each other more simultaneously
so could this be a federally funded
event or initiative
so i think if it needs to be if if the
um you know obviously if there was the
use was eligible
for those funds then then yeah it could
be what what i think this is true this
language is trying to do
is is really allow the agencies
to have um uh to be part
of the development and the use of the
infrastructure
around radio um and and bring those
needs
forward but have a have a statewide
level of review that makes sure that
they're going in a direction that
continues to be interoperable with our
other systems and so the funding is
is not really addressed because i
believe the intention is the funding
remains with that state agency
and and that's where the contracts
language comes in and i can see the
confusion there because it almost seems
like
we're limiting we're saying well you
can't spend more than two million
dollars on your system
um i don't know that that's necessarily
the um intent it but but
i but i'm not 100 certain my
interpretation is
it would encourage a discussion to have
with the agency and
desk because if desk is having these
discussions with all agencies
maybe agency a says we want to replace
all of our radios
at two million dollars however agencies
b c and d
are planning to do a large replacement
next year and we can get some synergy by
combining those requests
um and so that would be an indication of
well we want to limit
your ability to purchase those now
because this is happening in six months
and so let's add you to this request
instead um
so that that would be the way that i'm
that that i that i read it
thank you the other efficiencies would
may take an antenna anywhere in the
state they're going to be several state
agencies that have equipment on that
do we have multiple contracts do we have
multiple maintenance
agreements do we have i mean they're
just we looked at we broke down
this entire system to look and see who
has what where
and again we're very sensitive that we
don't want to
take this over but to ensure that you
know
that we unders you know that they
understand
and this is similar to language that it
has for it
you know purchases that's that's where
we looked to make sure that
the right decisions are being made the
equipment's interoperable and
you know that we're not um paying more
than we should for
something and that we actually need the
equipment so
i think it's i think it's
it shows good you know fiscal
responsibility and i think at the end of
the day
um the more that these agencies work
together
i can tell you um
director stewart from um cultural
resources has worked very closely with
um the uh emergency communications team
and they have already shared um made
significant savings with you know
purchases that didn't need to be made
they're working on you know you know
having them do the do the
maintenance and the upgrades to some of
the systems because
they're already there they're already
going there so the more you talk the
more you
you know you see where efficiencies can
be done but again i know you've got a
lot of reading to do
but if you look back to this performance
audit that was done in 2014
there are some things here that um
recommendations that were
spot on and we've been kind of chipping
and chipping away at them
you know little by little but back to
representative heath
the state has made significant uh
capital
uh improvements to the radio system over
the past six years and
right now thankfully it's in a it's in a
good place
we want to continue that moving forward
thank you it sounds like it's um a real
move
to reduce redundancy and could save
millions of dollars eventually thank you
okay are there any other questions here
okay
let's move on to the next area
i'm not sure there is a next area i
think that that actually concludes
the direct house bill 2 sections for the
department of safety
okay did this capital appropriation
repurposing
go away yeah that that found its way
into house bill 25 where
um more appropriately so because it
affected the capital appropriations
okay all right uh is there anything
that you would like to see in
hb2 that's not there besides
the unfunded position
um that's the only piece uh at this
point
um i i i think we're i think we're good
there there's probably one other piece
in hb2
there should be one other piece related
to moving the mechanical licensing board
over to oplc um that's standard
language just changing who where that
function resides um so at this time i
don't believe there's anything else that
we would be requesting in hb2
uh just that was unfunded position
authority
steve can i can i just show you i'm
going to share my screen one more time
because i
i've got the hhs section that does that
okay um and just
so so right here
is i think what we were talking about
take a look at that
so would your request essentially be to
be added to that section or have similar
section
you know but but to do the same thing
yeah that's that's on on first
on first gloss that looks like that's
the language that we would be requesting
okay yep thanks mickey yep
so that's section 21 uh for for the
committee if you want to take a note to
look at another time
uh we could um put an amendment in maybe
keep it separate so we don't
interact with division three section of
reviewing this for hhs
add a new section for safety or a men's
section 144 relative to their transfer
authority and have
two parts to it or something like that
okay and you folks have no
problem with the transfer of the uh
mechanical safety thing is that correct
that's correct it's correct
okay so we can can tell division one go
yep okay
um i will make a note of that
so mechanical yeah all right i
i think that's a good move
by the way i think we we we agree
um and we worked closely the fire
marshal worked closely with um
lindsey courtney over at oplc we met
several times and to coordinate
and it it makes a lot of sense
you know sometimes state government is
there's so many different functions we
have things
things end up getting in places where
they don't necessarily belong
and um when we can fix them we want to
fix them and that
this is a move that's uh that makes a
lot of sense
are there any other questions for the
commissioner or for steve
okay i believe uh that we have you back
next week one day i'm sorry i don't
remember which day it was
uh where we will be going through your
budget
kind of on what we call a line-by-line
basis
for the um division to
uh ask whatever questions they might
have on uh
on the funding what what you're looking
for
and um i'm sure that
you saw what came out of
um ways and means and their
and their funding levels so um
we'll uh we'll work through all of that
and uh obviously we won't be making any
final decisions next week but it
certainly will give
us an opportunity to uh
to see where we are absolutely no we
will we'll be happy to go through at
that level of detail
and at that time we'll also bring
forward some
um technical corrections for on for the
committee to review
things like a change in a a revenue
source that doesn't
have a a net impact but would make it
correct due to a keying error little
small things like that for consideration
you're you're muted representative
thank you i know mickey's looking
forward to making all of those
adjustments
that'll uh that'll get him uh that'll
get him started
as as opposed to uh
where we are right now so yeah okay
so um thank you very much
and um for the
division today's thursday uh
tomorrow we uh we get to talk to
uh d.o.t
and um we'll uh
we'll see what uh what they have to
offer
and obviously they will probably have to
um offer up uh some safety positions
to uh to unfund some safety positions so
we'll uh
we'll look at all of that tomorrow and
uh
and see exactly what they have now
they did i think you all got the package
from d.o.t and i know
that they tend to
refer us to um you know to that
so please make sure that on your um
on your dining room table like mine
uh or wherever that
that that is uh that is available so i
guess
i will see you all tomorrow morning at
10 o'clock right thanks everybody
our pleasure
thank you all